YO　YO　YO
ょ俺の名前は、はじめ。
YO　YO
YO
あ、、、
素人です。
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。
ラップの中にはフリースタイルというのがあります。
今回それで、、、アバンティーズと、
バトルすることになりました。
パン(はじめのこぶし音)
素人だけどね。。。
っていうわけで、
僕、全くの素人なんで
全然その、ラップとかわかんないんですよ。本当に。
何も知識のない状況で多分戦っても、負けると思うので、
今回もうラップ界ではすげー有名な方・・・
DOTAMAさんに、
ラップを教えて頂くことになりました。
ありがとうございます。
いやーすごいぞ！本当にすごいことですよ。
DOTAMAさんに教えてもらえるんですよ。
もう、やばいよ。
今回もね、自称YouTube界最強のラッパーらしいです。
どうしてくれんの・・・(はじめの心)
最強のラッパーですよ。YO　YO　YO
YO YO。俺唇ちょっと、厚めだけど、それを全部踏みにじむ
え～、ちょっとDOTAMAさんからですね、
僕に向けての、その、フリースタイルのやり方を
レクチャーして下さる動画なので、今回そちらを見て行こうと思います。
では、行きましょう。
こんにちは、初めまして。フリースタイルダンジョンという
番組でモンスターをやっている、DOTAMAという名前でラップをしております。
はじめしゃちょーさんが、アバンティーズさんとラップ対決をするということで、
はじめさんが、YouTuber界最強のラッパー
と名乗っていらっしゃるそうなので大丈夫だと思うのですが、
MCバトルに関してポイント、上げて行きたいと思います。
MCバトルは即興で相手をののしる一種のスポーツのような戦いです。
悪魔で完全即興でやることが大事です。
ライム、フロー、揚げ足ですかね。
ポイントとしてはその三つが大きくあると思います。
ライムっていうのは、韻です。
東京
例えば、東京、ドウドウ
ouou,ououで韻を踏んでる。それを、リズミカルに韻を踏んでる。それが、ライム。
フローっていうのは、それを、「とーうきょーう」だったり「トウキョウ、トウキョウ、トウキョウ」とか早く行ったり
で一番バトルにおいて重要なのがアンサーですね。
まぁ揚げ足取りとも言いますし。
やっぱ完全即興の言葉の喧嘩なので、相手が言った事に対してどれだけ面白く返すか。
判定はMCバトルはお客さんが決めるものなので、
一番どう盛り上げるかが重要なのでそこを大事にして頂けたら嬉しいです。
それでは、私がディスの実戦をしてみたいと思います。
おい！はじめ、お前にはない勝ち目
お前は何だ、社会経験もないのに社長名乗ってんじゃねぇ
ちゃんと正社員声をされてから言いやがれ！
I do'nt care
お前の動画たいていが大量系資源を無駄にすんじゃねぇ
資源ごみ、お前の存在自体が消えるのみ
「オリコーそうに見えて実はコミ症」ってサイバーエージェントのスタッフさんが言ってたぞ
つまり、お前の存在が疑わしい
誰もお前の才能をうらやまない
YouTuber？お前のことを監禁してやりたいぜ九周間！
ウホーウホー(はじめの鳴き声)
ウホー、ウホー
ディスって辛いですね。
これが、ラップってもんですよ。
アバンティーズの揚げ足を取る感じで向こうの悪い所とか、ディスれる所を狙って
それを上手いこと韻を踏んで倒していくという作戦でございます。
はい、というわけでDOTAMAさんの教えを僕が忠実に守り、早速アバンティーズと
ラップバトルをしてくるぜ。
YO！
♪～♪～♪～
「それでは、DJクィンナービート」
あ～！ウぜぇなおい！
さっきは、負けたが
そんなルールがあるとは知らなかった。
当たり前だろ！
次はちゃんとボコしてやるからな！見とけ！
反省してねぇな～
やろーぜ
「それでは、DJビンガッビート」
♪～♪～♪～
お互いにR指定さんと、DOTAMAさんに教えて頂いてやったんですけど
結構うまくなった気が・・・
そうですね～
そうですか？
まぁ結果的に僕の圧勝だったんで
また練習したほうがいいよ
はい、という訳で告知でございます。
今年の大晦日の夜八時から
AbemaTVにてフリースタイルダンジョン東西紅白歌合戦が行われます。
今回はなんと東軍と西軍に分かれて
そのバトルが行われるのでここでしか見られないバトルがあるみたいです。
R指定さんと、DOTAMAさんも戦いますしね
えぇマジで我々の師匠
そうです。
師匠と師匠のぶつかり合い
てことで皆さんもぜひこの番組を見逃さないように視聴予約をして見てみて下さい。
そしてAbemaTVはですね、登録不要で無料で皆さんも見ることができます。
ぜひ皆さん気軽に見れるので良かったら利用してみて下さい。
っていう訳でフリースタイルダンジョンやってみたら・・・
思いのほか、っぽくなりました。
そんなこと無いっすからね。
そんなこと無いです。
♪～♪～♪～
私ことですが、えっとベストアルバムを今月21日に出しました。
DOTAMAベストです。
もう名前もそのままです。僕の無駄に長いキャリアが13年分が詰まっていますので。
あと、1月にワンマンライブを開催します。
渋谷の「www」という場所で開催しますのでもしご興味ある方いたら宜しくお願いします。